ouais, ça devrait être
joli,
celui-ci a l'air
plus joli 4 Fox 50 700
Fox, nous viendrons ici plus tard aussi si nous en obtenons,
tu
sais, il
faut le laisser juste le laisser tirer un
coup ouais,
euh, attends, laisse-moi revenir tout de suite
avec
toi
comme tu
peux ok ok on refait la même
piste de vol en faisant un objectif plus long
ouais ok Rec là-bas juste un favori un peu
plus de cadrage sur l'arbre des
arbres ok ça a probablement l'air
bien ok donc ça devrait garder la vallée
en dehors de là ouais Vallée sur la
droite où nous étions
avant peut-être que si je descendais juste
sur les arbres ici plus d'
arbres, tout est les diapositives dedans, nous pouvons
commencer le tir ici ouais à
14 h 50, on a
tiré sur
deux bébés
là-bas, ils à  tout oh, ils ne
savent pas qu'ils sont protégés, je pense qu'ils
mangent 4 fo50 700
fo, je vais probablement laisser passer le
sperme mais je vais envoyer Brian
avec ses affaires, euh, qu'est-ce qu'il a fait d'autre  vous avez
besoin en plus du bman oui
monsieur, il y en a deux autres là-dedans,
lequel voudriez-vous
je pense que nous pouvons doubler ce euh ce
plan et juste le faire correctement euh depuis le
début ouais ok
alors on recommence ouais roule je roule maintenant
ok
ok  allons de
l'avant ok maintenant oui s'il te plaît
[Musique]
ouais comme tu peux euh ok bien s'il te plaît
légèrement à droite je pense que
nous devons être plus à droite non il suffit de
changer légèrement le cap vers la droite
là où le
B ok pour qu'on puisse commencer  le plan maintenant ouais
ok
ça
pour
ok ok va arrêter l'enregistrement je fais du
gros
plan en
roulant
pour
la taille de ce bol il pousse ce
petit bol hors de là
ouais oh ils essaient tous les trois de
le pousser hors
de
moi  sur un autre
je sors juste un peu plus large
pour
voir plus de groupe
oups on va refaire une photo parce que
euh on se déplace avec l'hélicoptère
à cause du
vent Zoom encore à l'intérieur ouais ok ensuite r
au milieu
ouais, je
viens juste de sortir, je
dois encore combattre Tailwind ici,
ok, arrête de bouger juste avant pour
ouais, arrête
ça, ok, c'est bon, attends,
continue, j'ai le flux là-bas sur la
gauche,
ouais, je fais
R, est-ce que tu bouges Peter ou est-ce juste  un
hélicoptère un hélicoptère qui tourne
ok ok ouais arrête ouais il ok donc on
va suivre cette
ligne et puis après ce euh ce
plan nous ferons juste un plan vertical de
l'arrière de la ligne jusqu'à l'avant de
la ligne ok dans  ordonne-nous de voir euh
qu'il y a des centaines de euh
bons qui marchent au milieu du
parc, je ne peux pas dire, je pense que je vais dans le
mauvais sens, je pense qu'ils avancent par là, d'
accord, nous avançons sur ma gauche
ouais, de droite à
gauche et vous voulez commencer par l'arrière,
c'est exact,
ouais et vous pouvez en quelque sorte continuer à traverser
la rivière pour attraper ces gars, ouais, ils
voudront probablement avoir ces gars à l'arrière aussi,
commencer par les gars  l'arrière ouais
devrait arrêter d'enregistrer ça, on va laisser
sortir oh on n'aura que ceux de
gauche et le P là-bas beaucoup trop loin
il y a un groupe de on vole juste en avant, on
vole vers
eux ouais, on va tout
droit, on
monte en ralentissant  lentement, elle
volait,
je ne peux pas faire
ça, faire un petit
grondement, arrêter l'enregistrement,
ok, je
veux que je tourne avec eux ou que je continue,
non, tu vas tout
droit, car certains font trop de
mouvements, se battent comme
des fous, qu'est-ce qui
va se passer maintenant
euh peut-être que je vais faire le tour de l'autre groupe
de l'autre côté de la rivière, celui-
ci laisse ça, laisse-les sortir un
coup, ils s'étalent juste finir ouais ok
finir il y en a
un dans ok ok
arrête faire vertical
ouais aussi lentement que tu peux J nous pouvons  perdons un
peu de hauteur, ce serait bien
avant d'arriver aux
arbres [Musique]. Je veux juste être sûr que nous ne
leur faisons pas peur,
nous aurons tous les deux des ennuis et ne serons plus jamais
dans le parc
[Applaudissements]
[  Applaudissements]
soutien-gorge travaillant sur le Delta à
936,
nous terminons le plan à la seconde où elle est
au-dessus de la
rivière.
Jos devrait juste aller tout
droit aussi lentement que possible,
j'espère que nous aurons un peu de lumière pour filmer à
nouveau
ouais, assez plat,
vraiment,
continuez tout droit.
Jos et Pete, continuez jusqu'à ce
qu'ils
disparaissent, il y a environ 10 secondes de neige
après ça,
d'accord, je pense que nous pouvons arrêter le tir, d'accord.